today's session we're going to address  many of the challenges that are  associated with research projects  especially getting those research  projects completed in a short amount of  time because typically they do take  years  at the minimum  several months and one of the things  that we've realized is that when people  join our different training programs  their background in life sciences might  prevent them from really getting deeper  into bioinformatics methods  allowing them to superficially know the  terminology but not really know how to  apply it practically  you will discover that some of the  training materials that we've designed  are specifically  useful for those that come from a life  science background without a lot of  technical engineering  skills and then you will be able to  really appreciate both the logic of the  analysis and technically how to become  independent and efficient in  bioinformatics analysis methods